tomorrow on CBS this morning David David  beg know his name hasn't changed he's  going back to Puerto Rico six months  after Hurricane Maria we are back on the  island six months after the storm to see  how things are and I can tell you  there's a whole lot more light in the  darkness than there was six months ago  we rode around with a police officer to  talk about the alarming spike in crime  and what's being done to combat it all  so we'll go to two of the hardest hit  municipalities to see how some things  are getting better but how in other  places conditions are just as deplorable  today as they were when the storm made  landfall  we'll see you Tuesday on CBS this  morning